and that is jonathan diaz on the mound
making his mlb debut 25 years old going
up against marte who's been standout in
the second half of the year marta
connects center field gets under it
brandon marsh doesn't have to move
and he makes the grab
and he walks
two of the first three a's get a free
pass three of the first four oakland
batters walk pender thinking big he's a
much better bat against southpaws he's
facing one now licking his chops
striking out
diaz gets the chase
matt chapman back in the lineup first
time since saturday payoff with the
runners moving he got him drama packed
top of the first from jonathan diaz the
left-hander
irvin
i'll sum it up this way strike thrower
yeah we like that he attacks
speaking of traffic it's really
important for the angels to get traffic
in front of ohtani otherwise urban as
most pitchers have done in the second
half of the season just don't need to
throw tiny strikes fletcher five for
nine lifetime against the a's lefty
makes contact little chip shot right
field classic david fletcher
one out base runner for the angels
and now there's the traffic
odd contact past second and it's a base
hit for ohtani fletcher's gonna move to
third on the bobble by pinder and he's
in there
they're on the corners ohtani's in
business that brings us to phil godzilla
gosselin since the all-star break 244
gosselin popped one up and on the hands
olson
has it it's jared walsh's turn
and it's weekly to second and gobbled up
and put away kemp to olson fourth base
on balls for oakland tonight
plus the hit by pitch and an infield
single
harrison got hit by a pitch to start
this game diaz has been pitching out of
the stretch yeah and that's a ground
ball through the infield and he's off to
a great start again
josh harrison with the rbi knock it's
one nothing oakland and everybody moves
up one station stays red hot got a
sinker here from diaz watch his hips
here josh is so good at turning on the
baseball marte will follow harrison
still nobody out in the second
marta center marsh coming in he has it
and everyone's gonna hold up
olson the bags full of a's
olsen connects deep center marsh
tracking back giving it a look at the
track and he's got it and this time it
is good enough to score a run in comes
davis make it two-nothing oakland on the
sac fly from matt olsen who continues to
add to his 100 plus first season that
he's hit triple digits in runs batted in
and that is all
for young
jonathan diaz
cole irvin i grew up 10 miles away from
here he was on the grounds crew at angel
stadium are you kidding me
suzuki clocks one deep left field it's
on its way and it is gone
the angels are on the board a solo shot
for kurt suzuki to light it up
so my efficiency note scott was about
his fastball and kurt suzuki said
i don't believe in that kind of map
nobody down in the second and a chance
for lagaris
[Applause]
nowadays that'll shock everyone and that
creates a fumble this is just perfectly
executed and sets things up nicely for
fletcher with otani on deck fletcher
first pitch swinging open space left
center field and the angels will grab
the lead
mayfield and lagaris come on down it's
4-2
david fletcher drives in two with the
base in small ball rules
gotta love it execution on the highest
order
and i believe this is what at bat number
six with the bases loaded for the
oakland a's
and we're only in the third inning
harrison connects it's in the air
and lagaris
is going to make the catch chapman on
the run and he is in there
oh and a bad throw over from the mound
will enable the ace to stay alive
a's get a run make it 4-3 for oakland
three goal glovers they're on the
corners and in center this is a strong
team on defense very weak matt chapman
charging bare-handed
oh we got him
the mats
showing off olson with the pick
side retired that is an amazing play
what
[Applause]
are you kidding me
that was disgusting
another base is loaded at bet hard to
believe to this point oakland still is
trailing in this game despite all the
runners on base
up the middle funny hop off the madness
could be too
beautifully turned
fletcher with the throw the ace will not
be able to do anything with the bases
loaded yet again
i have to let you know end the world
that there was an earthquake registered
about 25 miles from angel stadium
magnitude 4.3 it was in carson
california i didn't feel a thing brown
on the ground and this is going to bring
in a run for oakland
very productive ground out for seth
brown so the a's have caught up cannons
at third now 3-0
and that's past suzuki and the a's grab
the lead they're empty from kevin
swapped three times it is the microcosm
of the season for tony kemp though
pulls it oh what a stop at first by
walsh underhand toss they got him
gobble it up get it done jared walsh
mean glove work
the extension angels are going to pinch
run key and wong 2-0 on its way to
renjifo
to center starling marte racing in and
it's gonna drop and juan knew it he's
heading for third throw is there
starling marty makes a standout play
picks up the outfield assist inning
over 38 years old season number 14 for
romo
and a safe chance here's fletcher hayes
up a run fletcher reaches
fletcher in the air that should be no
problem for canon
over
a's hang on they win it 5-4
and it's win number 80 on the season for
oakland
sergio romo gets the job done
and just
barely avoids facing shohei ohtani with
the game on the line